it's e3 2017 I am rob joint here with
John Luke John Luke we played
Battlefront 2 on PC and had a pretty
good time but we were saved by the last
game and namely the fact that the last
game felt so messy random and
unorganized compared to what our
experience was with this game today
right yeah and I think the big thing
with that game was there were no classes
you know as a player there is no sense
of objective or role within your team
there is no reason to coordinate with
anyone else on your team in this game
they have clearly defined classes you
can play an officer you can put down
turrets you can assist your allies you
can be a specialist where you have a gun
that lets you shoot from a distance you
can see allies you can point them out to
the enemies you can play them out to
your allies so you have just a reason to
actually communicate with your teammates
like tell them what to do actually I
coordinate attacks which really just
adds to that sense of teamwork yeah and
you're looking at now opposed to the
last game which had just the partner
system you're looking at your entire
four-person group right and if you guys
are grouped together you're getting
battle points it raises right your valve
points right hand raises as long as
you're grouped together moving around
and then yeah of course you said like
you're switching around classes maybe
have too many support classes will why
isn't someone be an officer so that was
really notable and then I would say the
weapons was another complaints in the
last game here they felt so much more
diverse with you know your SMG high fire
rate low damage your support classes the
heavy Woking machine guns that you could
just post up in like a doorway holes
down
what I found actually really cool with
the fact that certain weapons had
different types of active reloads right
where you have namely like a rifle it
seemed to have you know the red area
where if you hit the red obviously
you're going to cancel your reload hit
the yellow you're going to get that
quick reload the green you know could be
a damage boost or maybe fire rate
increase Springs a lot of unique and
different traits each of these weapons I
found that very awesome and then for me
one of my favorite surprises with these
starships for the fact that you could
finally roll left to right in the
previous game we were very much locked
on like horizontal planes so when you're
getting into like a flip and a dive it
was so frustrating to get out of it
here you are consistently able to like
level your plane and figure out where
you are as far as like the horizon and
that was just so gratifying because I've
always wanted that battlefield 1 had
that it gives more meaning to being a
pilot and of course interacting
comfortably with ground targets that's
great and the other main thing was the
fact that the previous game didn't have
a health regen you know you would get a
dogfight say you win you have 5% health
left the next interaction you have
you're done there is no point of like
flying around with 5% health here you're
able to you know with a new Starfighter
hit that droid and get a you know a
quick revive with your health or you can
just you know hang around maybe on the
outskirts and have your health regen so
that was really great yeah and the ships
themselves feel like they have much more
of a defined role as well this time
around
in the original game you weren't really
able to interact much ground it was
random when you got a ship so it felt
like you weren't contributing much to
the overall team objective and this you
can with the battle point system you can
choose to be I'm going to be sewing who
focuses on playing as a fighter as
flying around you can shoot at the
objective you can shoot enemies you can
help your teammates out and so I feel
like as a pilot you're able to
contribute to your overall team totally
[Music]
Johnny you were also mentioning me like
you have rush feel and the operations
almost right yeah hey mode being much
more like more of a narrative compared
to like I was just a walker so you'd
have like a commander who is talking to
you and just saying like okay we need to
hold our ground we need to take out this
tank and then like okay they got through
we need to push back when you hold here
and just having that extra layer of tiny
story just like add like weight to what
you're doing we're in a previous game it
was like you're on top Walker assault
you see in the movie you know what this
is right just having that little bit of
story you're like really helps
the antique team has arrived in
commission despite severe damage
terminate escort program and begin
combat cycle phase 2 begins shortly I
also quite enjoyed the objective itself
like at the beginning it is it reminded
me a lot of battlefields rush motor
where it's like you know one side
defending the attacking and linear push
so in the first wave the gorge had this
giant transport that they are trying to
deliver and as the clones you have to
like pick up these ion cannons and try
and like target and shoot it down and I
wasn't able to get it shot down but I
believe if you do that it probably ends
the match early I soon yeah but they
were able to like get all the way
through and then they blow open the door
to the to the palace at that point you
have to then hold these different
sections of the palace and then if they
take that you then go all the way to the
throne rooms each area felt like
distinct in what you're doing
absolutely it felt like a refined
version of the Death Star DLC from the
previous game which was like these
babies yet you're going into actually
different matches that are disconnected
this one was all encompassing felt like
yeah you're playing one solid match with
yeah more like a narrative progression
row we contra clear the area
so yeah ultimately Val front two is
looking pretty good
I am excited I was a little surprised
yeah I'm excited to see more really we
just saw this one map on feed yes stay
tuned to a game spa for more about front
to coverage next yep